the Bachelorette is back in joining me
now are the two bachelorettes themselves
Kaitlyn Bristowe and Chris Milton thanks
for being here ladies thank you for
having good to have you all right so the
two night premier kicks off on Monday
and on night two one of you guys gets
kicked off so how brutal was that the
whole thing was just the most awkward
situation ever but I'm glad it was with
Caitlyn yeah well there's a lot of ups
and downs yes so you're still friends
after all this yeah oh yeah probably
better for anything it better I want to
get to know you guys a little bit better
as the two bachelorettes but so let's
start off with a fun game I'm ready for
a game would you rather yeah okay would
you rather your mom and dad walk in on
you or would you rather you walk in on
your mom and dad I'd rather my mom and
dad walk in on me really I doubt the
opposite oh yeah I think I would rather
walk in on them well I don't know oh man
well I'm walking on my mom and dad I'd
be like oh the best against you rather
Chris Hemsworth or Adam Levine Chris
Hemsworth Adam Levine Wow Wow Wow yeah
yeah we the one would be a bad choice
yeah
would you rather pay their Swift or Katy
Perry guys for your first date
Katy Perry probably Katy Perry as well
really she seems fun we'd rather
double-date with Beyonce and jay-z or
Kim and Kanye oh yeah hey Z come on like
I like I would not be able to say
anything that situation just be like I
defer to Beyonce every time yeah
all right here's one for you you ready
oh I'm scared it falls off your attic
whistle okay you're from your yellow
like oh or Josh Murray who of course got
engaged to Andi but they're no longer
together sprung crystal I'm gonna say
Josh cuz he's single so that macadam or
center no longer but no no no I look
like a mess no no Han at all